the u.s and nato have formally rejected
moscow's sweeping security demands
refusing among other things to rule out
future nato membership for ukraine in
its written reply to moscow's proposals
washington offers what it calls a
serious diplomatic path out of the
crisis
in recent weeks russia has masked some
100 000 troops near its border with
ukraine stirring fears of an attack
a military exercise on the ukrainian
border
russia is flexing its muscles while
washington has handed over a written
response to moscow's demands
our response to russia reflects what i
said in kiev berlin and geneva last week
we're open to dialogue
we prefer diplomacy
and we're prepared to move forward
where there is the possibility of
communication cooperation
if russia de-escalates its aggression
toward ukraine stops the inflammatory
rhetoric and approaches discussions
about the future security in europe in a
spirit of reciprocity
our responses were fully coordinated
with ukraine and our european allies and
partners
with whom we've been consulting
continuously for weeks
the response was delivered personally by
the us ambassador to russia
moscow wants nato to close its doors to
ukraine
something washington is firmly opposed
to
nato has also sent a written reply
rejecting moscow's demands
while we are
hoping for and working for
a good solution de-escalation
we are also prepared for the worst
and therefore in parallel with our
efforts on the dialogue track we are
also
increasing the readiness of our forces
and nato allies have also increased
the presence partly to
conduct surveillance to monitor to have
the best possible picture of the
developments in in and around ukraine
but also to provide a reassurance to
to allies
in paris there was diplomacy at a lower
level
the nomendi format brought germany
france russia and ukraine together for
another round of talks
the very fact that the work of a
normandy format has resumed
is a very positive signal
we had really very comprehensive talks
though they weren't easy
let's call it an audit of where we are
today
the next meeting will take place soon
maybe even in two weeks
and it would take place in berlin
we agreed to continue our dialogue
as the us and its allies wrestle with
russia's demands
a frosty atmosphere
spreads along ukraine's border
let's cross straight over to our moscow
correspondent emily sherwin emily
washington says the u.s is making no
concessions to russia's main demands
regarding ukraine and nato how is that
going down in moscow
well we heard a short response from the
deputy foreign minister alexander
grushko yesterday who said that
russia would
study the written response that it
received and
he also said you know look our partners
nato and the u.s took around one and a
half months to respond so essentially um
giving russia some time to respond as
well in that short response we haven't
heard from the kremlin yet and actually
vladimir putin himself has been
conspicuous conspicuously quiet
on the whole issue of ukraine in the
last month or so of course the fact that
nato and the us have rejected russia's
main demand which is a stop to nato
expansion eastern expansion that's bad
news for russia but i think that russia
went into all these rounds of talks that
we've seen in the last few weeks
essentially knowing
that
nato stopped nato eastern expansion is a
non-starter for the us and for nato
which is what they've heard again and
again over the past few weeks so
essentially it's russia taking uh you
know playing a high-stakes game of poker
including with these troops on the
border but i do think the things some of
the things that the west has offered
russia in the past few weeks are perhaps
of interest you know talks on arms
control mutual guarantees and
transparency on on military exercises
the question now is what do they do when
um you know they haven't had their main
main demand um met you know without
losing face what can they really do
indeed a high-stakes game uh the
question of course is what's going to
happen now with moscow's main security
demands formally rejected is moscow more
likely to
launch an incursion into ukraine
well that short response that we saw
from the foreign ministry certainly
doesn't seem like the russian side will
take any rash to decisions they're going
to be looking very carefully at what
they've been offered in that written
response i think the russian position
all along has been that they're not
planning an attack and indeed i think a
war with ukraine a full-out
all-out war would be unpopular here at
home many russians have um family ties
uh with ukraine so i think that isn't
something uh that they want but the
military threat is certainly on the
table with exercises planned joint
exercises with belarus in the coming
weeks emily thank you very much our
moscow correspondent emily sherwin
well for some further analysis on this
story let's bring in ekahat boza he's
president of germany's federal academy
for security policy that's a government
think tank he also he's also a former
ambassador and served as both diplomats
in moscow and washington
ambassador
thanks for joining us first of all give
us your threat assessment here how
likely is it that russian troops will
launch an offensive in ukraine
good morning terry um
i think we need to take that threat
seriously um
how
likely it is
perhaps only putin knows he keeps us
guessing
preparations are ongoing and we need to
work on the assumptions that
these preparations have some meaning and
the meaning is there is a threat so
let's take it seriously but at the same
time we pursue as we just heard very
actively uh the other path namely that
of diplomacy and negotiations
so the threat is serious you say uh the
u.s and some european countries see it
that way too they're bolstering
ukraine's defenses by delivering weapons
to ukraine now germany is refusing to do
that and has reportedly blocked estonia
from sending german-made weapons to
ukraine why
first of all
um
the weapons that you refer to these
formerly gdr weapons
uh are
a limited number of old weapons indeed
uh it is questionable whether they will
make a difference or not
to the ability of ukraine to defend
itself so that's not uh it's a red
herring
uh referring to you
germany
you're referring to it rightly
okay go ahead
sorry i can't hear you um yeah go ahead
sorry
what you what you rightly what you're
right is what you're rightly pointing
out is that the us and britain in
particular
are uh delivering weapons to ukraine
germany is not
the government has explained that that
is
primarily due to
its history
with
russia with soviet union
i think other countries
could accept that and could accept the
fact that not every country
uh in this western alliance has to do
exactly the same thing what is what
matters really is that everybody is
pulling on the in the same direction and
germany is very firmly part of this
western alliance very firmly also part
of this deterrence front that
consists of all these countries we have
put economic sanctions for example
firmly on the table
berlin's response though to russia's
military buildup and security demands is
widely regarded as ambiguous what impact
is that having on germany's credibility
with its allies
i think some of the voices we've heard
in
written commentary for example
has been simply exaggerated
i think if you look at the sequence of
events nato meetings later russia
meeting
eu meetings g7 meetings all of these
germany
was part of we agreed
with the us with our other allies
on how to proceed we have detailed talks
about economic sanctions and other
ways to make clear and send a signal
to russia and to putin
that we mean business and we're going to
stand our ground and i think germany is
firmly part of this group
so anybody who thinks that that's not
the case i think is misreading and
misinterpreting
the signals
ambassador broza thank you very much for
talking with us that was security
analyst beccahot brosa
thank you
you